in south johannesburg the streets are
full of people
trying to get home for the holidays a
tradition
that's been passed on for years down on
tati street
there's a soldier who came home at
christmas 75 years ago
after serving in the second world war
and we could hear him singing from the
roadside
his name is simon one of a tiny number
of survivors
of south africa's native military corps
i'll be at your service wonderful simon
how old are you
i'm about now 106
106. he told me
he signed up for the army back in 1941
well i went to the army because of
because of my property i could find that
in the only way
that i should rather go and die get to
the army
so then i left my parents
and then i went away
now i didn't even tell them that i'm
getting to the army
you didn't tell them no i didn't tell
them 80 000 black south africans
volunteered for the native military
corps
although they weren't allowed to fight
by the country's leaders who were white
instead they worked as guards laborers
and medical aides
mclanga guarded prisoners of war in
italy
were you afraid not at all
there's nothing that has made me to be
afraid of the army
because i was so i'm so good in the
anime
they promoted me he came back as a
non-commissioned officer
but he didn't get any thanks white
soldiers were given
new homes blacks got boots or bicycles
i was giving their bicycle i was giving
a bicycle okay
yes and then i had that bicycle of mine
how did you feel
about that well it was to me
it it was you know
i had to accept it about it really i
feel like the cheating that i've been
cheated by the government of south
africa
to give me a bicycle for many of his
fellow servicemen
the injustice continued into death
wargrave cemeteries in south africa were
segregated
blacks not allowed to share the same
plots as whites
and some members of the so-called native
regiments
have never been commemorated at all when
an amateur historian
stumbled on these books in south
africa's military archive
he found the names of a thousand black
servicemen inside
he's called terry carwood and he's
trying to verify the names of men who
served
and died for britain in the first world
war
the documentation was very
rudimentary and not a lot of effort was
put in
a lot of them are written in pencil and
over the
intervening 100 years i've faded the
commonwealth war graves commission
will help it's launched a process to
recognize these long forgotten
volunteers
he doesn't worry much about the army
anymore
when he left it he took up singing and
dancing
and led marching bands as well and they
have provided him
with years and years of joy
john sparks sky news in johannesburg
ha ha